remember Google glass it was thought to
be a groundbreaking technology which
would create a whole new market like
smart phones and smart watches it was
one of the most anticipated proximate
last 10 years as it was hyped up so much
before its launch but opponents release
reviews are terrible and sales were even
worse
eventually goo is continuing over us as
a consumer product in 2015 but now
Google glass is it back so what happened
and why did go glass fail and will they
fail again make sure stick around till
the end to find out
[Music]
welcome to Hari Saudis the cool glass
actually came with a strong welcome so
where did it go wrong the idea was to
mount a smart device on a pair of
glasses which sounded awesome in theory
but in reality it looked pretty bad the
Google glass design was very awkward and
unattractive
it was unsymmetrical and made people
look weird and people simply did not
want to wear this around town it looked
like it was more of a prototype than a
final part and I guess it was kind of a
prototype it was the first model and it
probably would have gotten better with
time looking more like regular glasses
and these glasses also drew a lot of
attention which was not all good
attention it was pretty expensive
hardware and it's not that hard to steal
a pair of glasses from your face so it
made it a huge target for robberies and
cool glass made people look geeky it
didn't boost her social image they
actually did the exact opposite Apple
watches make you look sporty high-end
the iPhones make you look classy but
this simply made you look geeky it
definitely was done associate acceptor
pod and that was with reason if you
actually think about it it's pretty
weird to walk around with the camera on
your head saying okay Google it's clear
why people wouldn't use it in public and
this really heard sales there was also a
lot of safety and privacy concerns when
I came to the Google glass most people
were not comfortable with this gadget
consistently emitting carcinogenic
radiation right next to her face all day
of course
phones and smartwatches also met
radiation but there's so much further
away from your head this was literally
expected to be in her face the entire
hey it also had a built-in camera which
made it a huge privacy concern you could
literally walk around and record
everything that you're seeing you can
record brand of people on the street
without them even noticing
and this also raised piracy concerns as
well you could just walk into theaters
and record the whole movie and post
online these were clearly not allowed
movie theaters and a lot of other places
as well so he couldn't even use it all
the time when you're outside of your
house the incorporated camera really
unleashed a lot of potential for the
Google glass but at the same time in the
wrong hands its capabilities could be
exploited for criminal activities the
vast amount of concerns relatable glass
really hindered its growth and the
development of Google glass was going
pretty slowly it had been two years it's
locked to the Google glass and nobody
really knew who were the Google glass
was going in the future
it was - a lot of confusion if it was
actually a finished product or not they
really made some bull attempts of trying
to market the goal of glass by using
skydivers and fashion shows but this
really didn't help there was problems
the device that people want addressed
before they bought the device for
example one of the biggest problems was
that it would completely stop working
during from her updates and of course
they had a terrible battery life that
people really love to complain about
Google glass was a pretty fluid
experience but there still was a good
amount of sluggishness that made a
pretty frustrating to actually use and
the lack of development made it clear
that these problems weren't going away
in the near future and this made new
consumer skeptical that they would have
a good experience of the product and
continue to have a good experience in
the future and this of course really
hurt sales and then there was a price
the first product wasn't even available
at retail stores you have to become a
good Explorer to be able to buy it and
it cost $1500 let's be honest that's
pretty outrageous that's even more
expensive than their already expensive
iPhones that people always criticize and
let's be clear sure this is a pair of
glasses with the tiniest crayon on top
right corner I'm sure technologically it
took a lot of money develop and produce
but just did not seem like it was worth
it for the public
as a result the main people who bought
Google glass were technology geeks and
journalists this seems like it is fine
non-issue but the problem is that this
subset of people don't actually benefit
from the features that go glass offers
when a product doesn't actually benefit
you you're so much more likely to get
really annoyed by the small
disadvantages and these people are
already pretty opinionated people and
considering that they're journalists
they're gonna share the experiences with
the world and that's exactly what they
did
they went out and share all the
negatives about the product like high
price low battery life and on a plane
design Tim Bergen said that he was one
of the first adopters to go glass and
his experience was terrible from the
very beginning he says that Google glass
now sits in his office Museum of failed
products there was also vast complaints
about the UI being horrible and the
connection being unreliable this again
gave Google glass a really bad public
image and this along with this really
high price made it one suitable for a
niche market people were expected to pay
a high price for a product that they
heard was a really bad experience so why
would they do that
and that was girls problem the key to
creating a successful product is to find
a demand and solve an issue you don't
make a product first and then try to
finally bug her interested in it
afterwards and that's precisely what the
Google glass did and this left it with
no clear purpose I'm not sure how the
simple concept was overlooked by the
Stanford engineers who work at Google
but for whatever reason go glass only
had two primary functions one you could
quickly capture images and two you can
get notifications from your phone but
there really were no practical daily
uses I mean how often were you going to
use the aforementioned purposes how
often are you going to have to take a
picture so quickly that you're not going
to be able to take your phone out I'm
sure that unless it was a very urgent
picture that needed to be taken people
would definitely take out their phone to
take a picture as it's so much higher
quality and how hopeful really are those
notifications going to be for the same
price you could even buy for Apple
watches which are already very expensive
and you could look at the same
notifications with a quick glance down
words or better yet you can take out
your phone and actually reply in an
efficient manner it really did not seem
like there was a clear purpose of go
glass and that as futures were more like
gimmicks even GUI jurors didn't agree
with the purpose of the glass some
claimed that you should wear them all
day in that shelf with all daily tasks
and others claim that you should only
wear in certain occasions but the thing
is most go back then and even people
today aren't doing things that are
benefit from the robust and when there's
no problem that people need solving why
are they going to buy it and that's
exactly what happened with Google glass
Google glass end up be such a big
failure that ended up in the Swedish
Museum of failure GU discontinued their
part in 2015 and didn't mention
successor for a pretty long time but
recently a second-generation device
named glass Enterprise Edition 2 has
surfaced this will match modern-day
Wi-Fi and Bluetooth standards but will
lack 4G Google announced the new
probably coming on 2019 but as it is a
business product that really isn't much
news on it they may have already started
handing out prototypes or even complete
launch of product to certain businesses
but either way the main thing is that
Google glass is back but glue is
distinctly aiming glass to engineers and
logistics workers the head-up display is
supposed to display schematic data that
they are able to compare with what is in
front of them this is a professional
version of the glasses and 10 mention it
is cheaper at $999 and it looks a lot
better - it actually looks like glasses
this time the right side is a lot longer
than the left side but this is not a
fashion statement people aren't going to
be wearing it outside so this actually
makes sense this actually has that clear
purpose and use and so it can actually
do well at least in my opinion it is
actually solving problems and making
processes easier and if this is followed
up with good marketing and really is
significantly beneficial I'm sure that
Google glass can make a comeback just
imagine that Google glass
one of the worst fillers in the last 15
years suddenly comes back and succeeds
it definitely seems like a hospitai
but we will have to wait and see
technology companies are always trying
to invent the next biggest thing and go
on big adventures to make that happen
however a lot of these dreams end up in
shambles
like did the girls glass that do mean
columns to go up glass was I was way too
expensive and had no clear purpose but
Goa has come out with a new product that
has a clear purpose and market and this
is also cheaper as well they solved the
two biggest issues that the original
goal glass had and seemed to be going on
the right track but only time will tell
that this will succeed but that's all I
have for you guys on Google glass
we should comment down below what
company you would like me to cover next
also if you guys like this video then
make your drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one
by till then I'm Hari I'll see you guys
on the next one